[Music]
[Music]
let's jump right in
and
before we start writing some code let's
just talk a little bit about
the neo4j graphql
library
so
when we build a graphql api
there's sort of two processes that we go
through one is designing our type
definitions in the schema for our
api
that defines what are the types what
fields do those types have how are those
types connected that's the graph part in
graphql is how the types are connected
uh and then there's implementing what
are called resolver functions and
resolver functions
are the logic for our graphql api how do
we actually go to the data layer fetch
data from a database write data to a
database
whatever it whatever it is
these resolver functions have the logic
for
basically
interacting with the data layer
and
with database integrations like the
neo4j graphql library it completely
removes the need to write these resolver
functions so
what you get for essentially free
is
the data fetching layer so we'd still
define our graphql type definitions and
that defines
the
graphql api
um but then the neutral graphql library
implements resolvers for us that
generates data fetching code
and adds a bunch of things to our
graphql schema like things for
filtering sorting pagination
gives us ability to add rules for
authorization
solves a bunch of problems that come up
when we're building
graphql apis
uh like this in plus one query problem
uh which is a performance aspect
uh so
really useful a library it's a
javascript library for node.js graphql
implementations the other thing
that we'll be using i said is neo4j aura
so aura is neo4j's cloud service there's
different tiers here we're going to use
neo4j oridb free which allows us to spin
up neo4j instances in the cloud and
start developing with them
so i'm going to go ahead and sign in to
neo4j aura
oh look some already signed in great
and i don't have any databases let's
create a database
i'm going to do auradb free
let's call this neo4j
graphql
and i can choose what region io is fine
and then i have the option of
loading an initial data set with movies
data or
a blank database to load our own data
we're going to do the blank database now
it's going to give me
a password
um
which i'm going to save
somewhere
since we'll need that later on there we
go
and yes i've saved my password
let's continue
uh so dev dot
neo4j.com slash neo4j or i'll drop this
link in the chat this is the landing
page for aura and again it's free to
sign up for aura and
spin up a database so that's
provisioning our database uh let's jump
back to
the graphql library page
and let's jump to the docs
so the neutral graphql library has a a
lot of different features
the basic idea is we write graphql type
definitions pass those off to the
library the library generates what's
called an executable graphql schema so
basically enriching the type definitions
that we specified originally with uh all
the
create read update delete operations
with filtering with pagination there's
even like aggregations that are added
and then
implementing those resolvers that is
sort of the core data fetching logic for
our api so i'm going to
jump down to this getting started
section
and
let's see if we can follow this to get
up and running
so we're going to be creating a
node.js app
so you'll need node and npm installed
npm is just going to allow us to
pull down some dependencies
so i've got an empty directory here
hopefully that is a good size i'm going
to do an npm init
dash y to just create a new
node project and
just use all the defaults
and then the next thing that i'm going
to do
will create an index.js file
zoom in one more
level that's
good enough there okay uh and now we're
ready to install some dependencies so
we're going to install the neo4j graphql
library
we're going to install graphql which is
the
javascript graphql implementation
and we're going to install
neo4j driver so this is the neo4j
javascript driver so
what the neo4j driver package is going
to do is allow us to
connect to neo4j and send database
queries so we're going to create this
driver instance hand that off to the new
graphql library which is then going to
handle
our
database connection
and then we have a few options here for
the graphql server implementation we'll
use apollo server apollo servers
is really quite nice
it allows us to
um basically just pass that schema
object that the neo4j graphql library is
going to generate for us and handle
network requests for our api
so we're going to install neo4j
graphql
uh the graphql implementation i'm going
to install the latest uh 15
version uh version 16 came out a few
days ago and i haven't tested that yet
so
let's pin to that and we'll install
apollo
[Music]
server if you can spell right there
okay so that's installing
let's
go to index.js and
start writing some code here so the
first thing we're going to do
is pull in the neo4j graphql class from
the neo4j graphql library
i will pull in apollo server
and the gql template tag this template
tag is nice it just allows us to
parse graphql strings in
our code
and we'll need the neo4j javascript
driver
and then we need some graphql type
definitions so these type definitions
oops not type type
const type defs
the
type definitions tell us
everything about the data in our graphql
api
i'm just gonna leave some very simple
type definitions single type movie
that's kind of a placeholder holder we
will come in and fill this in
later these type definitions are uh are
very important
so we will revisit those the next thing
we need to do is create a driver
instance
so we'll say neo4j driver
and let's let's set some environment
variables so neo4j
uri is going to be our connection string
to our neo4j aura instance
and
database username is going to be neo4j
but we will read the password
out of
environment variables
let's format that there we go and
let's set those now so neo4j
uri is going to be
if i go back to the aura console that's
going to be this string here
and neo4j password that's going to be
the
randomly generated password
that i saved over here
okay
uh let's go back to our
docs here's the docs
so we've got our driver instance uh the
next thing we need to do is create our
schema
so we're going to instantiate the neo4j
graphql class
pass it our typedefs and pass it our ufc
driver instant so it knows how to
connect to our database
and then finally we will just
create a new apollo server instance
and we're going to pass that executable
graphql schema object
to apollo server
so grab the schema
from our new graphql instance and then
we'll start apollo server
and
uh let's see in the callback we will get
the url
which will be like localhost something
like that
server ready
at
url
cool and let's
do a node index.js give this a run
so it's ready at localhost 4000.
cool so when we open localhost 4000 we
get this
um apollo studio
kind of landing page
and
this basically will redirect to
apollo studio which is like a
query workbench for graphql so it's
pointed at
localhost 4000
so my graphql api that's running locally
and
what apollo studio is doing i think this
is called the explorer piece of apollo
studio but what it's doing
is running what's called an
introspection query against my graphql
api that's running locally
so it's saying hey what are
the types in the api
what data do you have and then it does
really nice things like generate
documentation for us so i can see all
the entry points for the api
i can see
here are the mutation operations
i can see
[Music]
all the types available which is quite
simple i just have a movie which just
has a title
but that's quite nice and i also get
things like
autocomplete in this tool to write
graphql queries so for example i can
query for
movies
and their title and of course i get back
an empty array because
well
my database is empty it has no movies
in it so that makes sense
uh one thing we can do
if we go back to
our app is set this debug environment
variable
uh i think that's the neofj graphql
colon star
uh so that will set
the
oh i need to say node.j node index.js
there we go
um so this is going to set this debug
environment variable to nifty graphql
colon star
which is going to enable debug mode for
the neighborhood graphql library so now
when i run a graphql request in apollo
studio
there's a bunch of things that get
logged
to the console
so for example it says incoming graphql
request here it is no variables
jwt not configured we haven't set up
authorization that's what that means
and then
the cipher query
that was generated from this graphql
request
so it shows us
the database query that was generated
from this graphql record request that we
didn't have to write so notice when when
writing our our code here
uh
like i said the the common way to build
a graphql api is to write your type
definitions then write your resolver
functions that specify how to resolve
those requests from the data layer but
we didn't have to write those resolvers
the neo4j graphql library takes care of
that for us and here it's generating a
database query
which which is pretty neat that's that's
pretty powerful
cool so
let's
go back to our type definitions
and revisit this so in in the book um in
chapter two
we start talking about this idea of
graph thinking
uh and thinking of your application data
as a graph and going through this
data modeling and api design
process where we take our business
requirements and so the the application
that we build in
the book is a business reviews
application
so
i
can search for businesses businesses
have categories i can search for
restaurants restaurants near me there's
some location data in here
i have
users who are writing reviews of these
businesses in my api and
users want to sort of use those to find
personalized recommendations so based on
uh
based on my reviews for these businesses
what are businesses i might be
interested in those are the basic
requirements for our
um
graphql api
uh and so in the book we go through the
process of how do you translate that
into
a graph how do you then translate that
into graphql type definitions and kind
of what are the implications there so
we're going to go through that process i
like to use
a diagramming tool called arrows which
is i just add arrows dot app
i'll drop a link
to that in the chat
so arrows is a diagramming tool
that allows us to
create our
graph models but it also has lots of
other neat functionality
as well
which in this case is going to generate
our graphql type definitions
so we said we're working with business
reviews data so let's create a
business
node so this is our data model and we
can add labels to our nodes so nodes
these are the entities in our graph
relationships connect nodes
nodes
can have one or more labels which is
like a grouping
of the node so
this is the business label that's going
to identify
businesses and then we can add
properties so properties
are the attributes
the these arbitrary key value pairs
that we store on nodes or relationships
so we might have business would have a
name probably has an address
a business probably has an id
like a unique identifier
and then businesses are going to be in a
category
and a category is going to have a name
this is going to be like
restaurant bar
um bookstore that kind of thing
and we'll say that this business is in
category
now a common question that comes up when
you're going through these graph data
modeling exercises
are things like
should i model this as a node or as a
relationship
um
in this case we could model category as
a
property
on
the business node
[Music]
we could also model it as its own node
and so i like to think well it can i
uncover
some useful information
by traversing through this thing if i
modeled it as a node
that i couldn't if it was modeled as
just a property on
the business node
and category is a really good example
here because uh let's say
i'm gonna have other
businesses that are connected to the
same category so maybe
this is gonna be like all of the the
coffee shops
and this is going to be in category
gory there we go
and so now if i'm thinking of like how
do i find similar businesses
well i can traverse from this business
to its category
to other businesses connected to the
same category
and so that's useful information that's
something that um
i couldn't really do by traversing the
graph if i was storing category as a
property
on the business node
we're also going to have reviews
so
[Music]
a review it's gonna have
what an id like a unique identifier for
the review
it's gonna have
um maybe
the date that it was created
and
[Music]
maybe
uh each review is gonna have some text
i'm gonna say like this is a
horrible restaurant never come here
again stars
i'll give it
one star never come again
and so let's see the review is going to
be connected to the business we'll say
the
review
reviews the business so we'll reverse
that let's get this extra
node out of the way for the business
and then a review is going to be written
by a user so we're going to have users
a user is going to have a
i don't know maybe like a screen name
and we'll say the review is
written by
the user
so we've got categories businesses
reviews
users
and so
the
next thing we have to do is think of
well
okay so
we have an initial data model
but can i
answer
the questions that i have can i think of
a traversal through the graph that is
going to address the business
requirements
of my
application
and
this is where tools like arrows come in
really handy because i think the
graph modeling process is really an
iterative process we don't sort of look
at our business requirements and then
immediately
sketch out what our
database schema is going to be and
into the day
it's this iterative process where we now
we look at this graph we look at our
business requirements um so
grab those from i think the beginning of
chapter two yeah here we go so
as a user i want to search for a list of
businesses by category location and name
well i say okay
can i search for businesses by category
well sure i just search for these
category nodes and i traverse to the
business
and i can show whatever businesses are
connected to the category that the user
selected
that works and i work through my
business requirements and say hey is
there a traversal in the graph that
answers this question
yes
if we go through all those uh and we say
yes we can traverse this graph to answer
all of our business requirements
then
then yeah we're done
and we can
move on uh to the next step which in
this case is going to be
translating
our graph model into graphql type
definitions
we talk about
how to do this in the book you know sort
of
manually what is the syntax for graphql
type definitions but one thing that's
nice about arrows is i can kind of cheat
if i go to export
and then to graphql
i have my graphql type definitions here
that have been generated from that
diagram that we just
created so i'm going to copy those
and in the code here
i'm going to paste those
type definitions to replace kind of the
very
basic placeholder
that we had
okay and this is kind of a starting
point
you